alright Dakota and Hattie let's see her
a debt free scream yep three two one
[Applause]
fabulous absolutely fabulous it's so fun
but you can't do what they just did it's
impossible see that they don't really
exist we just made them up they're a
figment of our imagination and your
imagination we know this because you
Yahoo Finance's reporting that nearly
25% of Gen Xers and Millennials believe
it's nearly impossible to pay off debt
it isn't surprising or new information
the Gen X and Millennials have higher
debt loads than other generations
mortgages kids parents to take care of
student loans more financial pressure
than any other generation they're never
going Matt you kids this is reflected in
a survey the online lending division of
SunTrust Bank wait a minute a bank did a
survey that said you're always going to
be in debt hmm thank you son trust the
survey says it's nearly impossible quote
unquote to pay off significant debt I
don't know if it's 50,000 significant if
you're 23 years old
I'd say that's significant when they got
married had he was 23 Dakota was 27
they're 25 and 29 they paid out $50,000
in 23 months that's a long way from
nearly impossible nerd wallet Kimberly
Palmer says there's definitely cause for
concern looking at their finances the
takeaway is to motivate them to pay off
debt especially the high interest rate
debt it takes some motivation does their
steps to pay off debt faster Thank You
nerd wallet
appreciate that but we're meeting
Millennials everyday who don't think
it's nearly impossible as a matter of
fact they not only don't think it they
have proven that it's not nearly
impossible is it difficult to pay out
fifty thousand dollars in debt in your
first two years of marriage when you
make seventy or eighty thousand dollars
a year yes you sacrificed to do that but
you're living like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else it's a pretty simple thing guys
hope changes everything and it is
somehow a disease of the media that it
seems like they're the very things that
they want to report on or anything that
says there is no hope there is no hope
it is nearly impossible says a survey
from SunTrust Bank it is nearly
impossible says a survey from SunTrust
Bank to get out of debt as a gen Xer or
a millennial and then I meet Dakota and
Hattie well there you go fifty thousand
dollars paid off in twenty three months
but it's not really you getting the idea
I mean this is just stupid y'all it's
just stupid these young people are on
fire they can do anything they want to
do once they believe that they can do it
in this show and the Dave Ramsey team
believes in you
we're proud of you we know you can do it